[Musique]
simone veil bonjour je vous présente
florence belkacem qui arrivait avec moi
est ce que vous connaissez nos amis les
remous je les connais par la télévision
claire nebout cécilia n'aura richard
berry déjà et francis lalanne que vous
avez vus à ramatuelle mis en joue
absolument
est-ce que devant vous on peut allumer
une cigarette en bons amis on en a ça
arrive souvent ça arrive ça arrive
souvent et je ne suis pas du tout une
terroriste en la matière ce que je crois
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya tout de même
une campagne contre le tabagisme et où
les médecins ont justement demandé qu'on
évite de fumer à la télévision alors
c'est pas moins que ça gêne mais c'est
je dirais dans le cadre de cette action
pédagogique que je crois qu'on peut
faire un effort je vais faire un effort
jusqu'à la fin de cette interview je ne
fus moi bac se gâte
non je crois que ça donne vraiment c'est
une des choses sur lesquelles les
médecins disent que le plus c'est
l'image qui est donnée
à la télévision justement par des gens
comme vous célèbre qui sont les idoles
des jeunes souvent et bien le fait
le fait de fumer c'est certainement
l'image qui est en réalité très positif
pour le tabac est donc faux une
incitation vous avez commandé à périers
alors ça vous donnais pas d'exemple
l'alcoolisme dans bull non on n'est pas
alcoolique parce que parce que l'on boit
une coupe de champagne ça vous pencher
ce soir je préfère je préfère boire un
verre d'eau mais mais je le cabba ya
vraiment une question d'image
au deuxième tour
monsieur bart pour être élu est obligé
de de prendre les voix de le pen est ce
que vous lui demanderez de prendre une
position publique
je crois que même dès le premier tour il
est tout à fait souhaitable
toutes les personnalités candidat aux
élections présidentielles se situe très
clairement par rapport aux idées de
monsieur le pen et par rapport à ce que
représente le front national cela dit
qu'est ce que ça veut dire prendre
deuxième tour les voix de monsieur le
pen quand vous votez les bulletins de
vote ne porte pas un petit signe qui
montre que ce sont des voix qui viennent
de tel ou tel de tel ou tel type des
lecteurs d'abord je suis convaincu qu'au
premier tour
il ya des gens qui voteront aux extrêmes
je dirais aussi bien d'ailleurs
pour madame laglio par une espèce de
vote de refus ce qui d'ailleurs est en
soi déjà à une façon de manifester gens
seront toujours préoccupant qu'il y ait
des gens qui choisissent les extrêmes
par votre refus des candidats jettent
les classes signer aux deux du mondial
en battant lyon à risque d'être élue
avec les voix mais vous ne serez pas
vous ne serez pas on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui il y a une grande partie
des électeurs de monsieur le pen qui
viennent qui vient du parti communiste
même du parti socialiste et de la gauche
toutes les études qui ont été faites
dans les
dans certaines villes où il ya un fort
pourcentage de
de voir sur le candidat de monsieur le
pen sont des quartiers où il y avait des
voix de gauche très important donc on
peux absolument pas dire il ya tel
pourcentage vous telle voix viennent des
musulmans et les gens skate meetic est
très important en revanche cessé de se
démarquer très clairement quel match
excusez moi comme tous les les gens
comme tous les hommes politiques de la
droite libérale des gens qui disent nous
on fait bien la différence entre le pen
les électeurs devront bien moi je dis
pas je fais la différence entre les
électeurs et matthieu levain absolument
pas c'est pas du tout le discours j'ai
que je tiens je vous dis simplement
qu'on ne peut pas savoir jeudi plus je
dise ah ben c'est vrai qu'un certain
nombre d électeurs nous ont eus
partagent pas tous les
les sentiments et les idées de monsieur
le pen s'était bien qu'il ya une grande
partie de rejet et donc il faut bien
voir les raisons de ce rejet ce que je
dis simplement c'est une rouste à si
vous voulez matériel qui fait qu'au
moment où les gens votent
on ne sait pas quelle est l'option
arrêtée par raymond barre ça devient des
bombes de barbarie ce puissant mais les
bons libéraux mais ce n'est pas que ça
devient des banlieues c'est que vous
n'avez pas le moyen pour la lgv almunia
de savoir si ces 5% 10%
ça serait âgée à mes lecteurs un général
parce que très souvent beau père au 1er
août
on a tenté une expérience et arrêter la
fête de blanc rouge justement parce que
cette question nous importe c'est à dire
que 20 électeurs de le pen au premier
tour devient un électeur libéral ou
deuxième et on a demandé à notre ami
philippe guérin ici présents n'allez
hier la fête du front national a fait
bleu blanc rouge pour demander aux
militants du front pour toute notre aide
non ce qu'il pensait de vous ce qu'il
pensait des gens la loi on va regarder
le sujet on va regarder le sujet je
n'aime pas du tout simone veil simone
veil aujourd'hui fait beaucoup de flat
de deux plaintes de
sina gréasque en ce qui concerne ce que
tu dis est ce qu a dit monsieur le pen
et simone veil oublie simplement qu'elle
est responsable de la loi sur
l'avortement
ce sont des milliers d'enfants de bébé
que l'on tue dans le sein de leur mère
je trouve ça ignoble sueur au front
national
l'awb a sa place ici seulement
démocratie simone veil a droit à la
parole comme jean marie le pen
je n'aime pas du tout madame simone veil
je lui reproche en particulier sa loi
sur l'avortement qui entraînait le
génocide de de centaines de milliers
voire de millions de jeunes français de
deux petits français et de futurs qui ne
se réaliseront jamais une femme de
gauche d'une fan de huy de gauche et
éventuellement et puis bon à l'aap assez
facile à dire mais là rien à voir avec
visite
voilà qui n'a rien à voir avec le pen
simone veil bon ben je peux pas trop
dire parce que j'ai connu pas assez
m'enfin bon vous me poserez la question
sont n'importe qui je dirais non
c'est toujours pareil il y en a qu'un
c'est le pen la simone veil pour moi
c'est vraiment enfin je dirais c'est
l'objection politique c'est vraiment je
bon j'aurai je crois que j'aurais pas de
terme pour pour décrire une femme je
pense qu'il ya qui a été d'un cynisme
qui prend des airs de vierge offensée
quand elle parle du front national et de
tout ce qui pourrait faire le front
national c'est le diable je pense quand
même qu'il faudrait que elles
réfléchissent un petit peu sur tout ce
qu'elle fait sur les millions de morts
qu'elle as déjà sur la conscience les
soupentes et simone veil
beaucoup de mal c'est une femme
dangereuse
[Musique]
cette souris pas du tout il va falloir
vous soyez très exigeante avec monsieur
ben ali tout surpris je reçois du
courrier de ce genre fréquemment et donc
ça ne la prend a absolument rien si vous
montrer mon courrier il est quelquefois
bien que ça je le sais parce que vous
avez là je me place si vous voulez ce
n'est pas que je
je des douanes cet électorat pas du tout
c'est pas du tout que je trouve le
support parce qu'il m'attaque mais c'est
simplement sur leur idée quand on peut
trier là c'est pas vraiment ni votre
fille
ce n'est pas mon parti doit passer le
demandeur soir au micro il y avait des
choses beaucoup plus saignant mai mais
l'info devant les caméras ce reste
exactement comme ce pouvoir non mais
j'ai très bien elle se veut dire c'est
que je crois tout de même qu'à une part
dans les lois dans son exigeante avec
votre voix qui prennent des positions
fermes d'ici là vous parlez toujours de
monsieur 50 des coûts soutenue mais
écoutez pour l'instant je ne soutiens
aucun candidat parce qu'il n'est pas
candidat
oui j'ai simplement dit non je n'ai pas
déclaré alors je suis tout à fait désolé
puisque vous revenez là dessus avec une
espèce de certitudes j'ai simplement dit
que je suis du bf personne ne l'ignorent
je ne cache pas et que je pensais il n'y
a aucune honte à ça et que je trouvais
qu'il fallait flux d air est un candidat
aux élections présidentielles parce
qu'une grande formation politique dans
notre système constitutionnel n'existe
pas si elle n'a pas un candidat aux
élections présidentielles
c'est vrai que je trouve qu'il ya trop
d'ambiguïté je relis des
les commentaires qui ont été faits par
une grande partie de la classe politique
au lendemain des déclarations j'avais
fait sur dreux eh bien c'était très
populaire mais je crois que maintenant
il est vraiment temps réel et de la
prospective est non seulement la bonne
guerre mais il va dire que j'ai été seul
est dans la roue de personnes
pratiquement demain ne m'a soutenu et
que les propos tenus ont été même dans
la majorité modérée extrêmement dur à
mon endroit et que le courrier que j'ai
reçu je parlais du courrier le projet
toujours très intéressant le courrier
que j'ai reçue était aussi
étaient aussi imposant alors je me
réjouis de voir que maintenant tout de
même beaucoup ont pris position de façon
beaucoup plus clair mais c'est vrai vous
avez raison c'est vrai qu'il y en a qui
sont gênés par les déclarations
père michel moi qu'après faire
j'aimerais qu'on peut faire d'autre
et je crois qu'on ne peut plus
maintenant c'est ça me plaît et
d'ailleurs je crois que surtout la
classe politique devrait comprendre
qu'elle a tout à y est
[Musique]